JAMES NAKAGAWA >> Hi, James Nakagawa of Mobella
Healthcare. Ah-it's wonderful being at-here
at Davos. Everyone's talking about the economy
but I think what's been emerging more than
just the financial crisis is how-ah-the economy
is affecting people's health care.
And, as we all know-you know-health care is
a center of-ah-of everyone's daily life and
during this economic crisis-ah-it's much more
challenging. People are spiraling down. They're
going to go after creature comfort foods.
They're going to tip in and become diabetic
or they're not going to be buying their medications-ah-i-it's
absolutely terrible.
And I think that's where companies like us
now are-ah-are really helping to drive this
issue of-um-ah-mm-helping to provide a global
platform for self disease management, wellness
and prevention. And I-I just wanted to say
to everyone out there that-ah-the leaders
here are just phenomenal. They're all listening,
they're very proactive now. Health care is
taking center stage, and I think with what's
going on with the Obama inauguration in the
states-ah-it's coming to the forefront and
likely to be seen in Davos.